I'm Michael Strahan and this is Super
Bowl support alright we're gonna dive
right into these questions here we go
question number one is from me ponch
Oprah PhD smart person
why did coaches spring to the locker
room at halftime like you've been
talking to these players because they
sit on the bench for much of the first
half
what's that you even have to tell them
that they have it shared already hashtag
Super Bowl okay you are telling the
players about the strategy sometimes
you're just motivating guys and you're
just talking to guys now the reason that
you spring in at halftime is because you
need to get get into the locker and
address the entire team because on the
sideline you want to have the offense at
one point or the defense at one point so
this is a way for the coke to convey the
message to the entire team get in front
of them so we're gonna do this guys tell
them what to do get them excited send it
back out there in the second half with a
new fresh frame of mind that's what it
works alright Lisa from Florida so how
much is the Superbowl ring worth what's
the cost
anyone know looks pretty snazzy I have
no idea cuz I didn't pay for it you earn
it it's priceless to me I love mine the
thing I have in my life is the most
diamonds in it I have no other diamonds
pretty much except for that Super Bowl
ring and I wear it proudly
Nicole why does everyone have to run
from the locker room to the locker room
onto the field off the field
why all this running cuz if you don't
run you're lazy it's psychological
because psychologically if I'm the
opponent and I'm looking at you and
you're running and you have all this
energy even in the fourth quarter I'm
thinking to myself oh this person never
quits psychological plus you know what
make sure to shape you're ready to go
alright Jay Myers what will be wrong
with NFL overtime being given each team
a chance from a select spot on the field
40 or 50 yard line
with same rules 1st down etc just
doesn't seem right that if you are lucky
enough to win the toss the scored
touchdown that is all
the other team should get a chance Jay
you're right they should get a chance I
hate it too
teams of battling now to come to
overtime both teams tried you did a
great job
you both should have an equal chance to
win the game GB PAC see a dumb question
from someone that has been following
football for a while can you explain
what the five technique and the other
different stands a five technique you
have the center you have the guard and
you have the tackle anytime you line up
head up on someone it's an even number
anytime you line up on an edge it's an
odd number so a zero technique would be
the guy who lined up head up over the
center who snapping the ball a to
technique would be the guy who lined up
head over the guard and a four technique
would be a guy who lined up head up over
to tackle but if you shift to the
outside shoulder of the tackle that four
became a five the 0:v lined up is shift
become the one then a two of head up a
three of the shoulder a fourth head up
and a five is the shoulder that's how it
works pretty simple we're football
players we're not scientists we got to
keep the number very simple okay Adam
Everhart non-elite football mind here
why do coaches went down 15 optical for
two instead of kicking the extra point
after the first TD you know what Adam I
don't know I would kick the extra point
after the first TD then if I'm lucky
enough to score another one go for the
two then you know somebody says we want
the good news or the bad news
they just get the bad news first then if
they don't get it they got a lot of work
to do
Bilby why does every football announcer
incorrectly called a reverse a double
reverse like how do they know the
difference
all right the reverse is if I have the
ball the quarterback or whatever and I'm
going that way and I pitch it to a guy
going that way that's the reverse a
double reverse I pictured him he pitch
it to another guy who goes the other way
so you end up going the way that you
started in the first place that's a
double reverse I don't know why anybody
would call the double reverse a regular
reverse I don't know but that's what a
single and a double reverse is thank you
Bill
at NFL this is from Josh Sampson like
that name Sampson strong at NFL why is
the Vince Lombardi Trophy always handed
to the owner of a franchise first should
be hand it to the coach
hashtag Super Bowl nope you hand it to
the guy who paid for the coach and
everybody else on the team
the owner common sense come on Josh you
know better than that Jen me watching
football with your so after touchdown
then what happened
do they go back to the middle of the
field like center ice and then start
again apparently this was a dumb
question
you know what Jen there are no dumb
questions
so after touchdown - what happened -
they go why don't they go back to the
middle who feel like center ice and
start over again because that would make
it too easy you kick it off you team has
to drive the length of the field if you
started in the center of the fill every
time you got the ball and be too easy
for most teams the short field if you
just got the ball on the 50 every time
it'd be an unfair advantage X o X OCC
makes me uncomfortable when all these
guys kiss the trophy it's weird right
no that's like your baby I've worked all
this time nine months the baby comes out
it's mine
ah now if you see a guy trying to French
gets the trophy not that strange but
your regular lip lip that's nothing big
hockey probably one of the worst cuz
they get to take the trophy each player
takes the trophy for like a week I've
been around some hockey players I've
seen them do some things with that
trophy that you could not pay me enough
to drink out of that trophy - they all
drink out of it
you could pay me enough to kiss that
trophy I'll stay at arm's length and
just go like that next to it there we go
Larry B who remembers the classic
battles between Strahan and Runyan
legends hashtag SNF hashtag NFC East
hashtag nyg versus pH I I remember those
battles and that was one of the reasons
I retired because I couldn't take him
anymore
beating me down that's a big man six
seven or so 340 pounds strong as an ox
didn't like me he's in Philadelphia and
I'm in New York
rivals cold weather taking a beating man
I want to go back no my body doesn't
okay there we go I love those games may
Road Denis guys how do you manage
watching football and at the same time
tweeting about it with one of these
emojis
won't you miss some steps it's kind of a
game that fast-paced sometimes
slow-paced other times big play half is
nothing really happens sometimes so you
have time to tweet but I prefer just to
watch the game and not tweet at all
Jonathan Witter
hashtag Super Bowl earliest Gatorade
bath in Super Bowl history that was Bill
Parcells I want to say with the New York
Giants created by Giants Hall of Famer
and legend Harry Carson BAM there you go
history Jay BIC can someone explain to
me why NFL team continuously hires some
coaches who've been fired for being bad
and what career field does that make
sense oh these guys fired him because he
sucks let's see if he still sucks for us
and this dude you were soul mates
brother I've been wondering that too
your bad over here
what makes you're gonna be great over
here but the history of it sometimes it
works Bill Belichick Cleveland Browns
Bill Belichick New England Patriot
greatest of all time coaching so I think
you have to take chances maybe there's
something this coach shows that you feel
like works more in your system or your
team that it doesn't another team but I
do get confused sometimes because when
the coaches failed a few tired that he
still get the chance I personally have
an owner which I am NOT would say I must
we'll try somebody young and new and
fresh maybe I'll get lucky catch
lightning in a bottle and not hire
somebody who's been canned somewhere
else so that I could eventually fire
them in a year to myself I don't know
Nate bond our NFL coach interviews like
real people interviews our interviewers
like why do you think you would be a
good fit for this position tell me about
a time when you were struggling and what
you did to overcome that what are your
strengths and weaknesses you know what
Nate they pretty much are if you can't
sell the ownership and the general
manager you're not gonna get the job
because if they feel that you don't
believe in yourself if you can't answer
basic questions if you can't tell them
about your struggle than how you
overcame them and how you're gonna help
this team overcome their struggles cuz
obviously you're in there for a head
coaching job because the last guy
struggled in that job um you can't do
that you're not gonna get it so it's
very much like a regular interview maybe
with a little bit more strategy about
how you're gonna use those players who
are on that team to make that team
better and if you can do that you can
get a job Nate good luck on your
interview
Marcus Moser odd football question what
is more valuable a kicker who makes him
high percentage of short kicks or a
kicker who makes the high percentage of
long kicks but a lower percentage of
short kicks hey I'm here for riddles all
right Thank You Marcus
Catrin what is an audible in the NFL an
audible is say you have a play called
and you get up to the line of scrimmage
and the defense comes up and their play
the way that they're lined up would make
your play not
work at all you know by the way
everybody set up you have no chance
so you calling an audible you switch it
up you make guys move around to change
up your formation and it changes it to a
play that will work against the defense
that you see but all fences aren't the
only ones to audibles defense has them
too so if we see there and something
that we don't like the way we're lined
up we create an audible to put us in the
right position as well football is like
chess it's like you know mind games show
something be deceptive and make a play
out of it they can expect something out
of it but it ends up being something
completely different
that's what an audible is it puts you in
a situation where you go from a play
that would be successful to one that you
think would be Jamie Flynn do NFL
players play fantasy football do they
pick themselves if their friends don't
pick them do they get a little sad well
I played fantasy football one time then
realized that was much better at reality
football so I stopped playing other guys
do play play a lot of fantasy baseball
they play fantasy basketball if you're
narcissist you pick yourself and if your
friend don't pick you you don't get sad
you get even that's what you do Farhan
logy sub topic of the night appears to
be which at Super Bowl loss hurt more
hash tag Falcons or hash tag Seahawks Oh
hon it's a good question I would say the
Falcons hurt more Seahawks hurt just get
my shot lift a ball man give them the
ball game over you win
you went two in a row now me saying win
two in a row was very important because
if you're the Falcons you never won one
you're up huge we're covering that game
for Fox I'm on a sideline going I'm the
only one I picked the Falcons to beat
the Patriot I'm looking like a genius
then what I look like look like a bomb
because the Falcons just I do everything
wrong that you can do to lose a game
they'd never won one Super Bowl and you
had a lead to do it against the Patriots
I think that it's a lot worse and you
will regret that for the rest of your
life if you were a falcon coach or
player sadly
so I look like a genius for men and when
I picked oh here we go Amanda my
boyfriend just said that there's a
woman's with NFL is this true where have
I been
why haven't I seen this are there games
I can go to there is a women's football
league actually legends Football League
is a women's league that was started a
few years ago and used to be named
something else to launder a football
league but it became the legends
Football League and now I think this
year in 2020 it's gonna become the X
League
thanks very cool I love watching it so
make sure you find out go online check
it out top NFL Dolphins fan I see the
dolphin go go they play well it them for
you at NFL film study if you had to
guess how many quarterbacks in the NFL
are not allowed to audible mmm
most of them allows the audible because
if not you'd be a robot and your offense
would be stale and boring because you
would sit in one look and every team
would figure out what you're doing
before you've ever hiked the ball so
every quarterback have some ability to
audible some more than others obviously
you had Peyton Manning or you have Tom
Brady or you have Drew Brees who they
could do whatever they want because
they've earned it then you have young
guys who are new in the league they have
maybe one audible per play or on certain
plays it depends on how much the coast
trust you if the coach is the control
freak or not and how good you are the
better you are just like everything in
life kind of the more leeway you get
brunch words what's the best play ever
by a Superbowl losing team
Seattle when they make that great catch
by the receiver juggling the ball near
the goal line that put them in position
to where they should have run Marshawn
Lynch and in decide to throw a pass
that's probably the biggest one in
Hawkins I struggle to understand why
college football players would declare
early for the NFL Draft and essentially
miss out on a bowl game why not just
wait until after not having a go I am
genuinely asking answers welcome the
reason that a guy declared another plan
a bowl game is probably you know it's
kind of in the perfect world a guy would
declare for a bowl game he the team
would go to a bowl game he would play
that's a perfect world but now it's
different
so now a guy declare say he doesn't play
in a bowl game he's kind of thinking
about his future saying I don't want to
get hurt if I get hurt in a bowl game
that I'm missing out on potentially
being a high draft pick in any NFL so
you have to weigh the risk and the
reward just the nature of the beast if
we like it or not football is life whoa
what do you call your fronts with names
numbers or both explain why oh man they
it depends on the coach depending on the
terminology so most of them is very
simple bad it's very simple it's like
three words because we're in football
players it's a lot to think about out
there it's a lot of pressure 80,000
people screaming you can't say double
whammy triple x on the Y with the Z do a
little bit of males or bail on that
would aside abalone doesn't work dude
ain't got that much time you got to
think too much so is it's really like
you know what it's it's like a three
word 32 blitz man that's it you want no
32 blitz means I don't know it's been
too long I voluntarily forgot that was
super Bowl support you guys have a lot
of great question by the way but make
sure you tune in to see the Super Bowl
February the 2nd on Fox see it